vamos a hablar un poco sobre las
arterias y las venas y los roles que
juegan en el sistema circulatorio
quiero que pausa el vídeo y pienses
primero si tienes alguna noción de lo
que son las venas y las arterias bueno
una idea detrás de las arterias y las
venas es que en la mayoría de estos
dibujos las arterias están coloreadas en
rojo por eso escribir la palabra arteria
en rojo y las venas están coloreadas en
azul quizá esto representa la cantidad
de oxígeno que tienen una explicación
posible es que las arterias llevan
sangre oxigenada y las venas llevan
sangre des oxigenada es decir sangre que
tiene menos oxígeno
ahora bien esto es incorrecto
existen muchas arterias que llevan
sangre oxigenada y muchas venas que
llevan sangre texto oxigenada pero como
veremos esto no siempre es el caso
y ya que estamos hablando de sangre
oxigenada de sangre de c's oxigenada o
de los colores rojo y azul vale la pena
mencionar otro concepto erróneo algunas
veces se dice que la sangre de su
oxigenada es azul la razón por la cual
las personas creen eso es que si
observas tu muñeca puedes ver algunos de
los vasos en ella y esos vasos se ven
azules cuando los vemos desde el
exterior de tu piel en efecto esos pasos
son venas y allí es donde radica
esta idea errónea de que las venas como
las de nuestro brazo llevan sangre de
c's oxigenada y que este tipo de sangre
de shock sigue nada es azul resulta que
no es azul es de un rojo incluso más
profundo y la razón del por qué las
venas se ven azules es por la óptica de
la luz que atraviesa tu piel toca el
exterior de las venas y luego se refleja
de regreso
no es el color verdadero de la sangre
bueno hasta ahora no tenemos una
definición clara de qué es una arteria y
qué es una pena
así que cancelaremos estas definiciones
erróneas y una mejor definición es que
las arterias llevan la sangre desde el
corazón
mientras que las venas llevan la sangre
hacia el corazón traigamos una
ampliación del corazón justo por aquí
para tenerlo más claro estamos a punto
de ver porque esta primera distinción
entre venas y arterias no siempre encaja
vamos a imaginar algo de sangre que se
bombea desde el corazón así que cuando
se bombea para alejarla del corazón
justo aquí pasa a través de la aorta y
podemos ver las ramificaciones de la
aorta para que parte de la sangre pueda
subir a tu cabeza si eso no pasará
nosotras mai haríamos y moriríamos y lo
demás va acá hacia el resto del cuerpo
en efecto esta es la sangre más
oxigenada fluye a través de nuestro
cuerpo las arterias se ramifican y se
ramifican en vasos muy pequeños hasta
que forman ramas muy pequeñitas y es
justo ahí donde aportan la mayor parte
de su oxígeno a los fluidos de las otras
células del cuerpo entonces la sangre
sedes oxigena y aunque ya sabemos que la
sangre de su oxigenada no es azul cuando
este color se representa en muchos
diagramas así que haremos lo mismo y
estos vasos empiezan a construir las
venas a estos vasos muy pequeños que
conectan las venas y las arterias y
donde ocurre el intercambio de gases y
nutrientes se les conoce como capilares
así que después de pasar por los
capilares la sangre regresará al corazón
a través de las venas llegará a la
aurícula derecha
y luego al ventrículo derecho y después
se bombeará a los pulmones justo aquí
tenemos la primera excepción a la
definición incorrecta entre venas y
arterias estamos señalando a una arteria
incluso aunque esté llevando sangre de
shock sigue nada es una arteria porque
está llevando sangre hacia afuera del
corazón pero esta vez no la lleva al
resto del cuerpo la lleva a los pulmones
por esa razón se le conoce como arteria
pulmonar incluso aunque esté llevando
sangre des oxigenada así que lleva la
sangre a los pulmones y luego en los
pulmones de nuevo hay un intercambio de
gases la sangre se oxigena y después
regresa al corazón pero regresa al
corazón a través de estos vasos que
incluso aunque está llevando sangre
altamente oxigenada
se les considera penas ya que llevan la
sangre hacia el corazón así que estas
son venas pulmonares y después el ciclo
empieza de nuevo las venas pulmonares
traen la sangre a la aurícula izquierda
pasa al ventrículo izquierdo y de ahí se
bombea al resto del cuerpo a través de
la aorta para crear la circulación
sistémica tenemos una circulación
pulmonar que circula la sangre para a
través y desde los pulmones y tenemos
nuestra circulación sistémica que lleva
la sangre para iu a través del resto del
cuerpo ahora que ya sabemos la
diferencia principal entre las venas y
las arterias que otras cosas
interesantes podemos saber de ellas
bueno una cosa que es importante tener
en mente es que como el corazón bombea
las arterias directamente hacia el resto
del cuerpo estas tienen presión alta
y lo escribiremos en mayúsculas presión
alta por lo tanto si tuviéramos algún
tipo de accidente que espero que nunca
tengamos y nos cortamos una arteria
debido a la presión elevada saldría un
chorro de sangre mucha más sangre que
nos cortamos una vena
la mayoría de las veces solo nos
cortamos los capilares por ejemplo si te
pinchas un dedo solo es una serie de
capilares que se corta y es por ello que
la sangre sale muy lentamente y como las
arterias tienen una presión alta
las venas tienen una presión baja
presión baja y una forma de verlo es que
el corazón bombea directamente las
arterias pero una vez que la sangre pasa
a través de los capilares regresa por
las venas lentamente hacia el corazón no
se bombea directamente por esta razón
debido a que no tenemos la presión alta
para regresar todo el corazón en las
venas tenemos válvulas que nos aseguran
que la sangre vaya en una única
dirección dibujemos la sangre roja en
las venas para no mantener esa idea
errónea de que la sangre en las venas es
azul
ahora relacionado con el hecho de que la
sangre las arterias tiene presión alta
para transportar un volumen fijo de
sangre en un tiempo dado necesitamos un
volumen menor es por ello que las
arterias llevan un volumen menor de
sangre y por otra parte las venas llevan
un volumen mayor
para apreciar esta diferencia el volumen
de la sangre en las arterias es
aproximadamente 15% de todo el volumen
de la sangre en el cuerpo mientras que
el volumen de la sangre en las venas es
cercano al 65% aproximadamente 65 por
ciento y si nos preguntamos dónde está
el resto de la sangre bueno 5% está en
los capilares 5% en el corazón y
aproximadamente un 10% está en los
pulmones es momento de terminar este
vídeo pero el panorama general es que
las arterias son los pasos que llevan la
sangre desde el corazón y las venas son
los pasos que llevan la sangre hacia el
corazón
hasta la próxima